now if i would have had the information
back then that i have now
um it is impeccably clear to me that
that
that the the beginning of that disease
or what detonated it was um my divorce
and my mother's death
right now i can see very clearly that
emotions
cause that disease and what i needed to
do was work on those emotions to cure
that disease
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
on the show today is the cute and
adorable marcella
valadalid and she is a wonderful chef
she specializes more in
mexican cuisine but what we talked about
was a lot to do with how that's evolved
for her
and her own wellness journey
we talked about relationship with the
people around us um so
the episode is uh you know with a chef
but i i think that
we explore so many other facets of life
beyond just
cooking and i find her to be incredibly
inspiring fascinating and
what's great is it shows that we just
don't have to be one-dimensional we can
grow we can evolve
and we don't have to just be a chef or
just be a race car
driver we can become something else in
an expanded form and it doesn't mean we
aren't who we were but we can
rewrite our story or expand on it please
enjoy this episode today
when i finally reached out for to ask if
you would do this show
i was like oh my god we totally
talked about doing a podcast together
yeah yeah back when we shot the dish you
remember yes
100 yeah and i was just dude the guests
that you're
getting like i can't believe i'm i'm
sitting someplace that maybe a-rod sat
once
did he sit in this chair no i i i went
to a-rod
no but this is so cool so happy to be
back yeah this is fun i mean even the
you know 20 minutes that we've been
catching up before we started here
it's uh we connect on so many levels and
found that we did
when we met yeah back when we were
shooting that show the dish
and that was what made us go man i like
you i like you let's do a show that
would be a good idea
because we couldn't we couldn't handle
like i think you know
we relate on this level of depth and and
how
you know we just really didn't want to
talk about hot cheetos yeah
we and and what you could do with them
and if we liked them we wanted to talk
about you know
the universe 100 that was our
conversation in the car and i remember
getting back
home to like phillip and i was like that
danica man
she gets it she gets it so it was a
great conversation
so how's life been for the last two
years since we met
life has been really good um a ton of
changes
a lot of the stuff that we've been
talking about but like a ton of changes
in terms of
my health has forced me to
completely shift in a different
direction
in terms of what i do with my career but
the universe is wondrous in that way
that when you have the courage to make
that shift
the stuff that you're supposed to be
doing kind of lands on your lap
so it's been a slow process but it's
been a good one the last couple years
synchronicity is
100 so what shifted um
well first of all i realized what i've
known
or actually just kind of started working
on what i've known for the last
i'm 42 and i got diagnosed with hyper
uh hyperthyroid at 25 so i've known for
about 15 years
that my um my physical
spiritual emotional health uh
would be much more than just being
dependent on the pill that they gave me
the thyroid hormones that they gave me
to supplement
but i didn't want to go down that path
because that meant i couldn't be
cooking the foods that made my career
so for so many years i ignored
that part of it and i just kept getting
unhealthier
and unhealthier and then there were
periods when i would
just go vegan for like six months and
kind of recover a little bit and then i
would
a job would force me to you know get
back into those foods and
and i just came to a point where i was
like you need to make a decision
you need to make a decision if you're
going to
kind of you know create your life around
this
and not a condition just your life
circumstance this is what god gave you
this is what the universe
awarded you with what are you going to
do with it
and i've found it incredibly easy to
kind of pivot towards
um using my platform to speak about this
and speak about health and wellness and
especially in my community in the
mexican-american community where
food is the core of
everything like it's not just recipes
like our history our
ancestry our traditions everything is
centered around
food and cooking and for me to
be told that i can't eat nightshades
which are
tomatoes and chiles which are the
lifeblood of mexico
like what the hell am i supposed to do
now like what am i supposed to do now
but the reality of it is
that the amount of women that have
autoimmune issues and
thyroid issues is so massive that it's
not even like a niche market anymore do
they go hand in hand
those two or yeah are they separate yeah
no it's one implicates the other like
having a thyroid issue means you have an
autoimmune issue
explain what that is hypothyroidism
yeah so basically we have um a butterfly
shaped gland in our neck that controls
pretty much our metabolism
um and how our body functions mine
i i was diagnosed hyper thyroid which
basically meant that my thyroid was
um overacting um so i lost a ton of it
speeds up your metabolism
um you constantly feel like you've got
like rapid heartbeat
and that was like my life and i felt
that was just like my way of being i was
a very small person i was like
95 pounds um and at one point
which is one of the symptoms your eyes
start kind of bulging out of your eye
socket
and one of my aunts who's a nurse and i
had done blood work before because i
felt like something was off and this is
a really common problem with women that
have
hyperthyroidism it goes undiagnosed
and for a couple years i'd been doing
blood work and going to the doctor and
asking questions and they were like
no nothing's wrong your blood is fine
whatever and at one point my aunt martha
who's a nurse he's like your eyes
look like um your thyroid needs to be
checked
and i hadn't done that blood work
specifically and
lo and behold i went and got the blood
work and my body was
literally working um eight times
faster than what it's supposed to be
working in terms of metabolism by then i
was down to like
90 pounds um so the drastic measure of
taking radioactive iodine was taken
which is basically a pill that you take
um and the thyroid absorbs iodine
naturally
that's its job this had radiation in it
and the purpose of ingesting it is to
eradicate
part of your thyroid now if i would have
had the information back then that i
have now
um it is impeccably clear to me that
that
that the the beginning of that disease
or what detonated it was
my divorce and my mother's death
right now i can see very clearly that
emotions cause that disease
and what i needed to do was work on
those emotions to cure that disease
i didn't know that i was 25 i was just
like give me the pill most people don't
know that
i said don't be mad at yourself that's
and we're just coming to realize these
kinds of things
100 it's like one of the few good things
about social media
yeah that we're getting so much
information and i feel like it's my
moral responsibility to use my platform
to not only share
enchiladas but to tell people nightshade
free enchiladas
exactly um but to share this information
because i truly believe and not just
believe like i'm
living that life now that um the
solution
to a lot of these issues just lies in
like emotions and stress and
relationship and spirituality and
and and detoxifying yourself not just of
nightshades but of
maybe people right um right it got to
the critical critical point where like
now i can't have tomatoes man i
i hope fast forward 30 years we never
have to get to the point where we can't
have peppers and tomatoes because you've
solved the emotional problems when they
happen but that is
so revolutionary a hundred percent how
did you even
come to realize that part what about the
emotions yeah
um and when did you realize that
i think i have a sister who's been
studying
all of this stuff for long before i have
and she's been like the jiminy cricket
who very gently and very
softly has been like you have full
control
you have full control and sometimes and
what she was trying to say was
when you make the decision you will be
able to control
all of this and that is a really
freaking annoying thing to hear
sometimes because it makes you
responsible
totally right like the times that i've
posted about this
people feel like i am judging them for
taking
medication or having a problem or
exactly
um and my response to my sister would be
like do you think i like being sick
do you think i like that my hands swell
up so much that i can't wear rings or
that my eyes like i can't open them in
the morning because they're so puffy
like
do you think i enjoy losing all of my
hair
and you know she would just gently be
like
all i'm saying is that you have full
control and it took me years for me to
kind of absorb that and understand that
and i think the process of yoga and i
don't mean the asanas i don't mean like
being in the
studio like in like the poses like
that's a huge part of it
but reading about what yoga means just
like in general
um that has really helped me understand
that the journey inward is going to help
me resolve and control
all of these issues so then what did you
do when you realized that it was
you had accountability right because
that is the scary thing about
when you when you realize that you are
in control of your reality
yep you go oh my god i
i'm responsible and i'm accountable and
now i have to do the work
and the work i love seeing instagram and
the picture of the
like what spirituality what you think
spirituality looks like and what it
really looks like and it's like a mess
yeah but you never turn back so you know
what was your first like
what was your first phase of
and actually getting in there i posted
about this yesterday because it's been a
ten-year
messy road super messy on and off
and you know what's you know what's
crazy is sometimes
literally i will have these moments
where i'm like i wish i just didn't know
everything that i know i want to go back
to not knowing
i have those moments where i'm like i
wish i didn't just read this paragraph
in this book right now because i don't
want this responsibility i don't want
this accountability like
because it was more simple it was so
much more simple it was so much more
simple to just
not know that we have that power that we
are accountable that we can control it
um and it's been little by little i
think um
there's this philosopher who was a
mystic and like a social
activist her name is simon wales and she
says um
one of her like most famous like
whatever quotes is always
take the hardest option because when you
end up taking the hardest option it
usually means you're gonna learn the
most and you're gonna gain the most
and for me that hardest option was
literally
having the courage to walk away from
jobs
walk away from partnerships walk away
from relationships
and that wasn't pretty and i feel like
in a lot of those
self-help books that you can definitely
get a lot of information and
and a lot of the folks you know that
that you see on instagram like nobody
really wants to go
specifically there because who's going
to want to go on that journey
of like possibly being unemployed
possibly breaking up with your boyfriend
um possibly moving to a new city like
it's just too much you know and we just
want that
picture of health and wellness looks
like happiness and you have
zero problems and i posted about this
the other day too like
none of this eradicated my problems like
i still have them
all it just gave me a different way to
deal with them it just gave me
um accountability which is the most
important thing like having to go back
and see what i did that made i took that
job
i put myself in that relationship i ate
that food
like it makes you just become 100
responsible of every single interaction
that you have
and i think that's what this process
gives you that awareness that
take a moment to just
breathe in hold your breath analyze
what's going on
and realize what part you took in this
very moment that you're living in right
now and when you do that like
everything changes because nothing is
anybody else's fault you're responsible
i i i would say what's my [ __ ] and
what's your [ __ ]
right because sometimes there is someone
else's [ __ ] and it allows you when you
look from the observer perspective it
makes you look at it and go look down
and go
oh god danica this isn't that big of a
deal yep
he totally cares about you and you're
and you're like oh
yeah and then you get like i'm you know
dog you know tail between the legs and
you're like i'm sorry
or the other side of it which is their
[ __ ] every now and again
which is a lot less than my [ __ ] it
seems like but you look at it and you go
i'm not mad at you but this is yours
like i'm not even actually offended now
because
i realize it's nothing to do with me
yeah this reaction has nothing to do
with me totally
totally we were having this conversation
at sugarfish last night with philip i
was like
you hear this concept that the world is
an illusion right
or my sister's been telling me forever
it's an illusion it's an illusion it's a
concept that's really hard for me to
grasp
totally really hard for me i'm i'm
looking at this glass with water right
now it's not an illusion i can
touch it like yeah right here um but
it's not actually solid
exactly like if we kept the power if we
have the the vision to be able to see
like it's all energy and neither are you
and neither am i
exactly but anyway i came across this
arctic like i literally
googled because i need like empirical
like evidence of stuff like in my life i
relate to that
and i googled how much can we actually
see
like i wanted to see what the response
was oh yeah
and i came across a lot of
articles that freaking explained vision
you think at 42 i would know this stuff
i didn't know until very recently that
like
when you look at the world around you
um you don't have if your if your eyes
or your brain would try to absorb
everything that you see like literal
smoke would come out of your ears like
it's too much information it's like
overloading a computer like you
can't absorb everything around you and
the other thing that happens is we have
literal blind spots like a car
so what you actually take in is just the
important information
so what fills in like everything else
and those blind spots what fills it in
is your filter your life experience
like your trauma your experiences
um whatever you fill in those blanks
right
yeah so that for me was like
oh so that's what they mean when they
say the world is an illusion
like where literally each of us
individually
are filling in those blanks so it makes
it much
easier for me to understand that the
world
that you are seeing in front of you is
completely different than the world that
i'm seeing in front of me
and i i love that one of the papers they
ask like the researcher they're like
um so what's your conclusion like what's
the purpose of this study
and his response was compassion like you
see in veer from like a totally
scientific like explanation of eyes and
it's a reflection of light and that's
how you absorb it in the cornea and it
flips it upside down like
after this his response was
compassion because it helps people
understand
that we're coming at this life with just
totally different perspectives and the
only thing that you need to
do is kind of just shut up and work on
you i was i'm reading a book called
untethered soul legal singer i think
wrote it
but untethered soul and it's talking
about how
if you can the things that come in so
this is kind of a play-off of
you know we populate our world based on
through our lens
yes it also is part of the memories play
into it so much in your past in history
so
you know the idea is is that as you're
driving along the example given you're
driving along and
things just come in and they just flow
through you there's nothing really that
registers
or causes a reaction it just comes in
comes out happening you're just
driving along but when you have a memory
you see this like
old blue chevy truck you know and you're
like oh the blue chevy truck
my boyfriend and then that and all of a
sudden like you're stuck on the blue
chevy truck
and like you don't see anything else and
so it's talking about how your memories
then pull information from your reality
and and and distract you and make things
stand out more
and create your world basically they
create your world
when you have you ever had like
something you're worried about and then
all of a sudden you're watching tv and
it's like
all you see is stuff about that or
pregnant people when you're pregnant
yeah and you're like everything is about
pregnant yeah yeah
totally 100 i i was having this
conversation last night with philip and
like he was having trouble like grasping
like that idea right and i was like
it's like for example if you're like
walking in the mall and you see a woman
hit her kid right
for all of us that's a horrible thing
like you wanna or for
maybe 99 of us like 99 of us want to
jump in and tell her to please not hurt
the child
but how you metabolize or how you
internalize
that scene is completely dependent on
your life experience did your mother hit
you
did you hit your son that morning did
you was there
trauma um are you a social worker and
you see this every day so you want to
approach it with compassion
um do you feel compassion for the mom
because maybe you've been at that point
where you had
you know what i'm saying and i was like
the only way that you and i
phillip could approach that because his
his argument was like that's a bad thing
here and in china it's always going to
be a bad thing and i was like
yeah but how you metabolize like the
only way that you and i
are going to see or internalize
that scene in the exact same way
is if we approach it with amnesia
you know if somebody try that right and
scrubs it of everything um
that's the only way we're gonna have
like an identical life experience
but that's like that doesn't happen you
know sometimes i wish i could do that
like
sometimes i wish i could like when my
son fausto i get an email about
i got 700 emails a day from school it's
insane
but like if i get one for like a missing
assignment like i wish i could approach
him
with amnesia so i could just approach
him and ask him like okay kids so what
do you need like what's missing
instead of being like well you didn't do
it last week and i told you
if i could just erase everything that i
know about
start over to start over in that moment
yeah
i could be completely subjective and
just be like what do you need
in this moment and i think that's that's
another aha moment that i have
oh that's what they're talking about
when they're talking about living in the
now
which sounded so like such not bringing
your [ __ ] with you
exactly approach everything with like
amnesia so what
um what kind of [ __ ] have you realized
you carry along like
patterns or things like that oh i'll
give you a really good example
um my last argument with phillip i don't
know if he's gonna be kosher with me
sharing but
i won't say exactly what it was about
but i
wanted to go like on this yoga thing
because i'm obsessed at the moment
and the reason i am with philip actually
is because he is the opposite of the
macho male prototypes that i grew up
with
like in my mind you usually either
repeat the pattern or you do 180.
and i repeated in in my all of my
relationships before philip
and then i had like this crises i did a
180 and i looked for a nice human
which was him um so
i was having in my moments where i feel
tired and sick and or weak or vulnerable
i revert
to that stage where men are [ __ ] or
um controlling is that what you grew up
with very much
okay so your dad was like that yes well
he wasn't an [ __ ] but he was
very it was just a way macho mexican
what
it's his what he says goes and there's
just no
there's no um there's no conversation
there's really no communications there's
rules and you follow them it was very
military like i would have to get up at
6am
clean my room do bed sit like nobody
could ever be sleeping in his presence
or sitting like you always had to be
doing doing cleaning reading whatever
no tvs nothing so that was my life with
my dad and
honestly like he's my biggest teacher
like the reason i've been able to
accomplish a lot is because
a lot of that so it is what it is um so
i approached philip and i'm like
i'm going on this yoga retreat and i'm
not asking and he's like
what are you doing right now like when
have i even why are you yelling at me
how are you yelling at me
why are you being hysterical right now
but i had created this like whole
scenario that he was gonna push back
and it was gonna be drama with the kids
and like
all this stuff and eventually i walked
away and walked back and i was like
i did not need to do that i apologize
but
yeah but i do that often with him he
kind of laughs at me at this point to be
completely honest with you because he
knows i've known him for 20 years
yeah um but i definitely go back to that
it's like in my dna
it's like i can't scrub that one off no
matter how much yoga i do
like my automatic sometimes response
with men is very much like
you're not going to tell me what to do
yeah nobody's really telling me what to
do that's all in my head
i mean sometimes it's familiar it's just
a familiar pattern
totally it's like i grew up with um i've
done like we were talking about we sat
down
the amount of self-help therapy
self-improvement work i've done this
year has been off the charts and so
yeah it's been i have cried
so much the first few months of this
year good and my worthy years feel
so like because i've realized that for
me i
don't have like a lot of feminine energy
to me it's like the go go go like i
relate to
my dad called i said 8 a.m every day in
the summer woke us up don't waste your
day
do something it was like i lived in a
man's world in
a sport and so i like had to couldn't
show emotions and
you know i was it didn't matter anyway
no one asked how i was doing
and um so feelings don't didn't exist
yeah and they were and they were
weakness and worthless
yeah totally the what purpose do they
serve
none what's slowing me down they are to
be ignored
a hundred percent yeah that's how i grew
up too have you ever heard i
i'm i'm gonna go to this uh institute
called the hoffman institute i don't
know if you've ever heard i think i have
i probably have i probably read
something about it at some point what
happens at the hoffman so it's a week
and you go and it's like no phone no
nothing no you it's like a deprogramming
reprogramming and they get to the root
of your
traumas and your patterns
how scary if you want the information
i'll let you know but it's a
like they even tell you like plan to
spend a couple days when you're done to
reintegrate
anytime they need to use the word
reintegrate after a week you're like
where but where are you taking me today
to be integrated
yeah to a place super deep in your heart
yeah and
that's a place that's not been super
accessible for me so
do you relate to that having a dad that
was so
yeah and and in this process of
when i started this whole like yoga
thing like my
honestly my intention was just working
on my physical body
my intention was just working on my
physical body i had
at the time i was like we're gonna take
baby steps we'll deal with trauma
and childhood and all that a little bit
later right now because here's the thing
my aunt marcel we have the same name uh
always used to tell
say this to me like all that stuff that
you talk about like that your sister
talks about self-help
like it's so impossible to get there if
you don't physically feel well forget
about emotionally like you need to at
least
have like not be exhausted uh
not feel like you're you know not have
inflammation like at least
try to control the physical part of it
and then it makes it a little easier
because you actually have the physical
energy to go down those
really deep emotional like journeys
right so i was like
i had a plan i was like i'm going to
recover my physical body first
baby steps and then i'll work on
emotions and trauma when did this
process start then how far i'm just
trying to give a timeline of like how
long
it's all been i'm still working on uh
physical but it's been like four months
okay and i think a couple of weeks ago
i had this really weird experience
where it was like day after day of
having dreams of
really bad relationships that i never
really talked about
um a boyfriend that was murdered at some
point
20 years ago um another that one that
was
very emotionally abusive um and it was
like day
after day of dreaming of these men
and it wasn't like they were part of a
conversation like when i was just like
well something weird is going on with
this
with this i need i need a little more
information and i just happen to be
reading
and it's not how that happens like the
universe like that's how it work a book
about
um the asanas um written by a woman
who's a mom
and in one little paragraph she explains
that you need to be aware that when you
start doing
deep breathing um what is in your
subconscious will be brought
into your consciousness because that is
the purpose of the practice
to there's a saying in yoga that says
you can't eradicate
anything until you see it so the purpose
of the practice is to bring
everything from the subconscious to your
conscious and i'm just telling you after
like
four months of reading like there are
people that i'm not claiming to know
anything about i mean this is just what
i've learned in mind i love hearing
about your journey
um there's just so much information um
so i read that and i was like okay so
that makes sense
so i was like but i need to go a little
deeper i need to understand what the
hell to do with this information because
i'm i'm not comfortable
like it's not comfortable to relive
those very uncomfortable moments in life
and i literally and i was at a yoga
retreat um
the week after and i went up to uh
our instructor who who was reading from
the sutras a beautiful book and
afterwards i told him my experience and
i told him what happened i was like just
you just need to tell me what to do with
this like i just need instruction
because i don't know
okay the memories came from the
subconscious into my consciousness like
he
tell me what to do and he thought about
it for a second he's like your awareness
is enough
you can stop there your awareness is
enough
keep doing that yeah i was like thank
you
i don't want to do like any weird things
right now he's like
keep doing the exercises keep doing the
breathing just see it for what it is and
let it go
and it kind of just happened that way
like it was brought up i saw it i
talked about and it was it's kind of
there
but it's no longer something that takes
me to a
um kind of anxious nervous
um kind of fight-or-flight sort of
statement
so just by seeing it and recognizing it
well what was the thought that helped
transform it into
something that wasn't so emotionally
loaded i think it's just having that
conversation i just talking about it i i
sat philip down i was like i just dreamt
was like whatever
and i told my sister and i told the
teacher like i just had conversations
with people about it and that was enough
for me to just bring it up to
where i could see it where i could speak
about it because honestly i think
there's just so many things that exist
in our brain that we don't realize that
we've never
verbalized and i think i realized that
i'd never had a conversation about that
guy that was killed
yeah and i'd never had a conversation
about that other guy that
made me feel like i was an absolute [ __ ]
in our the whole time in our
relationship like i never
really told anybody about it it's so
alive in your brain that you think that
maybe you did have that conversation
with somebody at some point
but i think it's brought to the to your
consciousness so that you can
let it out i do think that there's some
kind of magic
in um saying things out loud like it's
like um
it's not only held in the subconscious
but also in the energy body too
and so those are like the feeling like
what
i don't know about you but sometimes i
have things
resonate in my body before i recognize
them in their mind which is really
freaking annoying yeah the somatic
response to like
anything 100 like to the point where you
can't eat yeah this isn't like super
common but it's happened a couple times
and so i think to myself the first time
it happened i was so confused and then
after that you get a little more
familiar and you're like
buckle up what what am i pushing down
what am i
what's going to come up yeah yeah um but
but there's some kind of an alchemy
going on
when you get it out of you it's like
there's it's like as if there's um
uh as if it's like just taking it out of
you yeah like the words
are part of part of it yes i believe
that 100
i went to um a
long time ago i think that place
actually started my journey
it was like a retreat but all of it was
centered on the fourth step
the fourth step of aaa which is
basically um
um i don't know what it's called in
english but it's basically when you get
everything out like your
life story it's like a confession okay
like a purge or something courage
confession yeah
um and for literally
two days this is crazy i don't think i
never shared this like publicly before
but for two days you are writing
and i wasn't a journal keeper wow i've
never been a journal keeper i need to
work on that but for
two days you write down what you
remember
from the moment you were born to the
moment that you were standing there in
front of that person oh my god because
you
you get assigned a person and you write
and you
write but you write everything down
everything that you can remember and i'm
not necessarily talking about oh i went
to trip to disneyland no i'm not talking
about like the bad things like the
things that you think cause trauma the
things that you think shaped you the
things that you think
um need to be dealt with basically
so it was like it was there was a lot of
writing and after you
write it you read it
you never sleep you never eat in this
whole process for two days yeah
um a little extreme i know wow
but you did this yes oh my god it
helped me
bring up stuff that existed in my
body and in my brain and in my um
you know we talked about filling in the
blank spots could you imagine all that i
was filling with those memories or with
those experiences and now they were just
kind of
out and it's a huge release
i mean i'm not i don't consider myself
like a practicing catholic anymore but i
really do feel and i've never
honestly believed in confession but i
feel that
in theory like the practice of it i
think that's the purpose of it to
release you like you said of this
almost somatic response that we have to
life what what do you do now
as a parent to try and
mitigate the damage because you know
you're going to cause a little because
nobody's perfect
we're human and we talked about that
there's so much awareness that the
awareness is almost crippling
because there's so much awareness that's
the going back to before where it was
simple like you just went about your day
and you just there's
so much awareness better tamales and
everything was fine
i started doing all this work when my
teen was already a teen so could you
imagine me going back on like 12
13 years of like oh my god
everything i did was wrong
i think kelly ripa said which i think is
brilliant that like kids are like
pancakes you ruined the first one and
then the rest of it
kind of come out okay and i didn't ruin
him because he's actually a great kid
but a lot of this process is also
just being very kind to yourself and
compassionate to yourself
and understanding that it is just the
human condition even if you grew up with
like
mother teresa to be a healthy adult you
have to go through the process of
unlearning
to to to have ownership of yourself
and your life and your emotions and your
spiritual spirituality like
all of us have to go through this
process of unlearning
nobody escapes that nobody people can
die without going through it
but to get to this place that we're
trying to get to
so hard the process of unlearning has to
be a part of it
and i and i'm aware of that as i raise
my children i am aware
that they will have to go through some
sort of process of unlearning all the
[ __ ] that i passed down to them
like i'm doing my best and i say this to
moms all the time because they write to
me all the time and i say
do you love them and the response is
always yes and i was like
that's that's all you need to do at this
point yes educate yourself read be
compassionate be kind like
but do you love them that's enough
and i think that's what sometimes i just
need to look in the mirror and say that
to myself do you love them oh my god
more than life
more than anything yeah yeah i mean just
the fact that
there and i say this to them all the
time the fact that you're even reaching
out
means that you're aware that there's a
part of you
that wants your kids to be healthy and
happy and strong
and that's enough yeah like that's
enough just love them and try to educate
yourself but that's enough but
definitely
um my two little ones are
definitely growing up in a different
world than i was they
they they sing mantras they light the
incense
they do breathing techniques they know
yoga um
they philip is jewish so we're
interfaith
at home we it's important to me that
they
understand that there is one
god but the paths to get to him are
many and i didn't grow up with that i
grew up with that i grew up with there's
only one path
and if you don't you're not on that path
you go to hell
and that's it it's not non-negotiable
and once you get off the path you pretty
much can't
get back on um so for me it's really
important that the kids
understand that it's we're all connected
there's one god
there's many paths um you will struggle
i'll try to provide you with the tools
philip and i are on the same page which
is the most important part
um and he just goes along with all my
craziness which is
amazing have you always been on the same
page
well i actually now that now that i
think about it i think
i got on his page
of just we have a story
we were together when i was 19 and he
was what 23 24.
and when we both lived in la i was in
culinary school and he was an agent or
yeah he he just got out of the mail room
at william morris like we were
both just starting our lives and i dated
him for a couple years and then we got
you know i went back to mexico got
married he got married and then we got
back together 15 years later but i
remember
back then my thing was like ugh he's so
boring
he wasn't boring he was just a nice
person and i hadn't i didn't know what
to do with that philip i'm looking for
drama i don't know if you know this but
my childhood taught me to look for drums
a hundred percent
i didn't realize until the the here's
what happened i had like a total
mental breakdown about six years ago
like they cancelled
my mexican food cooking show on the
network and
i was like a single mom i've always been
financially responsible
more or less for my teenager and it was
like the world was crashing down so i
was like
what do i do go to deepak chopra that's
what i did i went
i did i wanted a good spot totally so i
went to the one here on the coast that i
think it's called
um and i do the whole thing and it's
about trauma and like i've always tried
to do the work right and i'm sitting on
this like white little bench
six years ago probably six seven years
six years ago
and i'm thinking who do i who i want to
speak to right now and the only person
that would come into my mind was philip
not even my sister who's been my
conciliari like my whole life like in
that moment i was like
i just want nice right now with like
zero
judgment and no strings and just
kindness and it was his face
and i called him out of the blue and i
was like what's going on and we hung out
for a few months and then we started
dating and then
david happened and that was that
have you thought more into uh like soul
mate twin flame
kind of like that whole world of the
people that are in our life like i had
met aaron
in 2012 yeah but we didn't get together
until the end of 2017 like 2018.
yeah but i wouldn't have been ready for
him then yeah i would you know i get
that i wasn't ready
like if we would have been together back
then yeah i would have ruined it i would
have messed it up at some point i would
have too yeah
i i i was not i mean like i only just
know
now i'm not in my feminine and he
requires that
softer place that slower place that
water place
and i am trying like hell
and still sucking at it yeah and i
wouldn't have even known what that meant
back then
yeah and it would have been a total
disconnect yeah but you're aware
which is the difference yeah but these
people they're in our life for a reason
i think so 100 i think i also believe
with every fiber
by being that what brings us together
what brings you together with whoever
your partner may be
um has a lot to do with your
dysfunction and a lot to do with
like your trauma your past experience
and that's why they say whatever is like
really super cute and attractive about
your partner eventually becomes like the
most annoying part of him
but that's just because what drew you to
that person
was what you were lacking or that
stability but eventually you have to
meet
in the middle like you both have to work
on like
philip i'll give you an example i'm a
freaking mess with my finances
and he is like you know
perfection-winning solid solid
spreadsheets excel
like the whole he's got a 10-year plan
what's dynasty
um well i don't know his uh birthday is
may
6th okay what sign is that
um i don't know about march april may
june july
wait sorry you said what time is it
um he might be a taurus
is he i don't know april yeah
which is super steady and super
methodical almost slow that's him just
salt of the earth so in the in the
beginning that's like
huge because he's like don't worry about
it i'll just take care of your stuff
which is great
um but then like life happens and those
conversation happens where he starts
like asking me about it and i get really
uncomfortable
so the purpose is not to have your
partner fill
that void or maybe it is a little bit in
the beginning because that's what makes
them attractive
but to do the work to learn from your
partner so they're not
filling that void and i think that's the
hardest part
to get to that point where you know
okay it's my turn to do the work and
kind of move you in the middle
instead of you solving this issue of me
looking for a father figure looking for
somebody to clean up my finances looking
for somebody to
give me financial stability like they
will fill those voids right
but i that's my feeling like that if you
don't
work on either the financial
independence or resolving the issues
of that you feel that you didn't have a
father that was present like if you
don't
deal with those issues i feel that
eventually becomes what
destroys your relationship like that you
have to work on those issues
and i think it's been such it's been a
learning process for me especially for
me for the
with what men have been to me in my life
in terms of philip like
so many times of the day i have to i
catch myself
going back to that place i catch myself
but now i can stop myself like maybe
maybe 80
of the time so grateful for people who
can help us
get to a slower place like yeah i am
because
i run on high energy and it's so nice
because
it's not nice it's hard but it's
empowering
um what is the uh what is the
greatest lesson that he's taught you
kindness i think kindness and i said
this yesterday when i was walking out of
sushi i was going to
do some shopping and i walked back and i
was just like you're just a really nice
person like thank you like you're just a
really nice
guy um and i just wasn't used to it nice
and it's such a simple concept but i see
how he interacts with people and i've
always been
so guarded and so like ready to pounce
and so
always on defensive um
and he's not he approaches life in a way
that is so beautiful to watch especially
because we're raising children together
like i know when i get in that space
i'm smart enough now to separate myself
from the situation and kind of let him
take the kids
because i'm like if i'm gonna if
anybody's gonna be injected with
anything right now let it be his
niceness
so let me walk away from this situation
um
just his ability to
see beauty and pause and take in beauty
i remember i used to make fun of him 20
years ago because he would literally
just look at this guy and be like
what a beautiful day and i was like
you're such a cheese ball
right god whatever obviously it's in
california
a hundred percent like that was me he's
like we should put on like we should go
hike hiking like
no let's go drinking at the sky bar like
i was in a totally different place
and now that is what i find the most
beautiful about who he is
this ability to just take in beauty
and share it and to raise my kids with
somebody that's so aware
that the world has he's just a really um
i'm glass half empty he's glass half
full so i need to work on getting my
i'm filling up my glass yeah yeah it's
such a process
it's such a process to reprogram yeah
you talked about your sister
and i have a super close relationship
with my sister i in fact i
call my sister oracle because she's so
intuitive and just like seems to know
she's younger younger but i call her
oracle
and i know you have a super close
relationship with your sister and we've
only just touched on her but i want to
talk about her more because
when we had met back a couple of years
ago you were telling me how she was on a
she was going to india for a few weeks
on like a
a yeah some kind of journey
it was a kundalini festival i don't
remember exactly the details but she's
been
um and she's talked about this openly um
her journey with depression uh
and uh being dependent on medication and
how
she was determined um
to resolve the issues that put her in
that depressive state
and she knew that to be able to do that
she needed to you know withdraw from the
medication so that she could see
everything feel it so she could feel it
and see it
so in that how old was this um
i think she started with this like 10
years ago okay
um and in that pro like in that time in
the beginning
like my mom died 10 years ago and and
like her world came crashing down
because she had she wanted to let go of
the medication and she wanted to face
all of those issues and we were dealing
with the death of my mom and that
started her journey
um and i remember when we would have
these conversations i'd be like
no i don't it's a pandora's box man i
feel ready i'm not ready i'm not ready
i'm not ready
and she and i think we have this
beautiful
incredibly strong relationship because
we're so respectful of one another's
paths like i
we don't we rarely have an opinion on
on one another's life unless we like ask
for it like
um there's a lot of respect there's a
lot of respecting each other's space
and in our homes uh uh you know
she's we're always kind of there but
we're not
in each other's lives i don't know if
that makes sense but we're
very respectful of one another's process
and for years she would just plant a
little seed here
or a little seed there and eventually
those seeds kind of begin to blossom but
she has been my
biggest um mentor
and guide in all of this and she's it's
it's funny because she's very similar to
philip so i guess i gravitate towards
those people because they balance me out
she has
this um and i tell her you need to work
on that because that's dangerous she is
incapable of seeing
your faults she's incapable of seeing
faults in people
so she can connect with anybody and she
will see beauty in anybody and she will
she will meet this person she's like
we're going to be best friends she'll
she's everybody wants to be her best
friend and she wants to work with
everybody and she wants to help
everybody and it's like
and i'm like you need to filter a little
bit better but she is
um like i'll meet somebody and i'll be
like that guy's kind of shady like are
you sure you want to do the retreat at
that space above and she's like no but
he's amazing
she'll give me a list of 20 things why
that person is amazing
and that's like her magic like that's
her super superpower like she
is she sees beauty in everyone
no matter like she's done a lot of work
like inside prison so she's
able to see beauty even in those
scenarios
like she's able it's a beautiful thing
to be able to do
and in the moments where i wasn't able
to see beauty in myself
uh she was that person that would
constantly be like
you are this you are that you are that
because i've had those moments where i'm
like there's nothing good about me
nothing not a thing physically
emotionally spiritually like in those
black holes like she would be the person
that would be like
you are this and you are that and you
are that and you are that
and she would bring me out so she's been
like that person
on that journey just the little angel
kind of on the side
that just pulls me out and philip is
very much the same way they're both very
much the same way
i'm really lucky you gotta say
but like where we started you create
your reality
this is true i'll take credit for it
yeah
yeah i chose those people well i chose
philip i didn't choose karina
what do you think about that as far as
like chose those people
i mean i'm sure being in the yeah or
eastern philosophy we
decided before that we were going to
take this journey together i do believe
that
and i'm beginning to try and absorb that
concept that there was a before
this kind of brings me to the thought i
just had about how you grew up
and how you live down in san diego with
you know people you grew up with and
like your people and
um family and how important family is to
you
and so this might be relatable to people
listening
who are perhaps on a similar journey
where there's an evolution of belief and
so
how does that show up in your world
where maybe you do have this
concept now of um reincarnation
or um you know souls reincarnating and
soul contracts or
uh you know how does that show up in
your world
does it even i guess is the first
question popes love
mexico because we are the most devout
people right
the most devout people like whatever
pope
is in power he will come to mexico like
three times a year
because the crowds are massive like
and i grew up with that i actually went
to see pope john paul in breckenridge
colorado when i was a teenager yeah i
saw him face to face
wow but anyway uh
it's really really hard it's really
really hard to make that shift to open
and the way that i see i remember when i
started doing yoga when i was like 25
years old because that's kind of when i
got into it but it was just for like the
physical part of it right i've done
gymnastics it looked really interesting
like i could do this it's a nice i did
it that's why i did it doing it whatever
i want to look like a yogi too
100 i just wanted to look like a yogi um
and back then like that was like taboo
like even even yoga oh my gosh you have
no i you need to come down to tijuana
hang out with me
but even still like i remember my sister
had like a buddha
in her home and it was like some of her
friends or
our friends who were really conservative
is like why does she have a buddha
like it's like a thing it becomes like
um
like i said you're getting off the path
there's only one way to god
and there's very specific there's a very
specific road to get there and
if you get off that road you are you're
ex
i can't get married exactly i get
married again
get married again in a church like i got
divorced i'm i'm supposed to go to hell
now like it is what it is
um you're too nice to go to hell i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna
um i also believe heaven and hell are
here but anyway that's a whole
i agree with that too we talked about
that if you want to totally i agree
but anyway i feel like it's
all in um educating yourself
once i started doing a little bit of
reading of
why priests aren't allowed to get
married or
how um so many of the passages in the
bible
are actually just repetitions of things
that existed in like ancient greece or
ancient
egypt or this whole idea of jesus being
born from a
virgin one of our aztec gods the
feathered serpent
it's the exact same story um
same for osiris and egypt like if you
just educate
if you just google it like this is not
me being a part of like a satanic
sure cult yeah like this is me just
educating
myself about the roots empowering myself
on the roots of my
religion um you
just realize that it's just much bigger
than
than you know what we're what we're
taught growing up in terms of my
in my personal experience the catholic
faith yeah there's just
too much there's there's other religions
there's other ways there's other path
there's other um and it's all
out there yeah for you to read and
google
i think there's so much there's truth in
all religions and none of them are the
one right like
they're all the one and not the one all
at the same time right there's there's
i think there's there's good and there's
bad in all of them totally um
actually it's kind of like a person
and that's why i love this whole like i
said i'm trying to read
as much as i can to understand as much
as i can not about the yoga like the
asanas but the yoga life and if you if
you
were to like bring it all down to like
reduce it
to like one sentence is just like
do good and be good be kind right
don't be like be
in your next life no but like that's
just it man
be inclusive be kind be compassionate
that's
whatever your religion may be so what
are we here for then
what do you think have you thought about
that that's way too deep
ah jeez what are we here for well
if you if you if you connect to
you know all these eastern ways of
thinking we're looking for ascension
and on whatever trip we're on it's just
like we're trying to get closer and
closer and that's why we have to do the
work
and i like doing the work i'm actually
it's taken me to some really
really uncomfortable places but i feel
that i've become a better
mom for it so just that reason alone
is um enough motivation for me to do the
work
i know it should be about me and me
empowering myself and owning it and
controlling my health and my
spirituality and my emotions but
i've seen um
what it has done for me as a mother and
i think that's been a big
motivation that's inspirational yeah
it's been
motivational yeah it's been it's been
yeah because i know that sometimes we're
not willing to do the work for ourselves
but when you're a mom you're willing to
do
anything for that child anything
so in those moments where i'm like i
cannot do this right now
they're the ones that are like get your
ass up and
yeah work on whatever you need to work
on right now yeah
for sure so what comes next then in this
evolution
of you know marcella the chef
um wonderful things well i'm writing a
kid's cookbook
what that's so great super excited about
that's awesome
um i partnered with little libros um uh
who's helmed by patty rodriguez who's a
latina uh a small publisher and
she writes these like beautiful books
about the icons that i grew up with in
mexico
that if i were to name them you would
have no idea what i was talking about
because they're full on like mexican
but like lucha libre and stuff like that
and just really cute stuff that i grew
up with anyway those are the books that
i've been reading to my kids for last
three years
and she approached me and she was like
do you want to do a bilingual kid's
cookbook and i'm like
where do i sign that's cool 100 so
um because of all of this stuff that
i've kind of been reading and
researching and
i really wanted to center of on this
theme of um
the tree of life yes because it's the
true life
it exists in every culture and every
religion
and um it's so
i mean some people believe that the uh
the secrets to like our genetic code are
hidden within the
some of the interpretations of the tree
of life and there's just so much
beautiful information about it um
but like the tree of life is like i i
need to explore this
so it's gonna be kind of like without
giving too much
like the recipes that make up my family
tree
so um we're gonna go down a little
journey
and we're going to be collecting recipes
from my family members until we
build that family tree and all the
significance of
the family tree and the tree of life and
you know
that's the theme of the book like i want
it to be deep that's cool
i want it it's meaningful deep and
meaningful and layers on layers
well i mean as a latina we're living in
this moment right now
where um
a lot of us feel like we need to kind of
cancel out our culture to
not receive any hate like it's almost
like assimilation is coming back it was
gone for a while and it's kind of coming
back which is horrifying and really
scary
um but i was like this is an opportunity
for me to
make kids want to explore their past and
their roots and their tree
and be really proud of where they came
from and maybe
a lot of us don't know you know one
generation back or two generations back
so maybe this book will inspire these
kids
to you know maybe first generation
american but yeah
how many generations back and where in
mexico or where in latin america and
you know i just want kids to feel really
proud of
where they're coming from so that's
that's huge and that's really exciting
um because the universe is incredible i
keep getting approached
uh to do work on
all of these healthier versions on the
foods that i grew up with
so that's going to be where i'm going to
end up so the cookbook the kids cookbook
will be
rooted in authenticity from growing up
but then
as a separate project is something where
it's like taking
you know traditional foods and making
them healthy
yes that's what my following is asking
for because it's crazy because i'll post
like a traditional mexican recipe like
enchiladas and i'll get like whatever
great amount of likes
but then i'll post a version of it that
is either like
paleo friendly or anti-inflammatory
or you know and that's when i'll get all
of the messages
because my following is mostly women
yeah
most of us are over 40 and that's when
everything starts to shift
everything happens after 40. yeah and
how long i'll be 38 next
month this month i'll be 38 in a couple
of few weeks god bless you my child
i'm not that much younger but yeah i i
really
i felt a massive shift when i turned 41
actually
in terms of my physical metabolism yeah
sorry to say no but you're in such good
shape and you work out and
it's it's about prevention there was no
prevention in my life like
right and no prevention when you think
about the fact that the body regenerates
itself yeah
like on a cellular level i don't know
what the order of it is but basically
you know we have an entirely new body
every seven years so i would say for the
last seven years i've been doing a hell
of a
much better job than i was the seven
years before that yeah
and so who's to say that i'm just gonna
get older or worse right
there's a possibility of becoming
younger and i would love to abandon the
thought of like 100
old getting old and having to have
things happen
because we're getting more educated
totally
but a lot of us you're i think i don't
think you're going to have that issue
like to be completely honest with you
but the grays are real
those are real do handstands they give
you more blood circulation
in your head and you don't lose hair and
you don't get grays like we will do
those as soon as we're done
holy smokes okay i'll take my hands off
um but
uh yeah i think i need to start speaking
to that and everything is coming in my
direction in terms of speaking
to that like i get so many literally the
question i get asked the most these days
are like just what
just tell me where to start yeah step
one just give me step one
so what is that my next that's my next
project system is step one
good good i think that's great because
it's step one we're just getting more
educated and it doesn't mean that we
we weren't purposely trying to do a bad
job before we just know more now
so let the evolution happen totally
totally it's it's it's just
all about educating yourself and it can
be such an
overwhelming trip when you start to
educate yourself
especially now that there's so many
um
there's literature to support everything
now everything
everything like you have to do bacon for
that's all you eat and you will be fine
and there will actually be science
like telling you why bacon's so good for
you and just eat bacon
so it makes it really really difficult
so i
always said if i because they asked me
this these questions like what are you
eating a day
and i'm like no like if i can
teach you one thing it would be to
develop
intuition that would be my gift to you
develop intuition to and that's what's
so great about yoga if you
if you go inside and you and you
detox so much to the point where it's
not your
um addictions screaming familiarity
but your actual body asking for touch
or sunlight or a protein like if you
get to a point where you detect then
that's my personal goal to detoxify so
much of like
stress and food and chemicals and
toxicity that i'm
able to hear my body again because i've
always been very in tune but for the
last 10 years i've been sick so i
completely
it's like i can't hear it all i hear is
the addiction the cravings the to drama
to sugar like that's what you hear
that's what's screaming
um but that would be like if i could
if i could find the formula to teach
intuition which is
what i'm working on right now that's
eventually what i would like to teach
like they say that if you're so in tune
with your body like you don't even this
is too much information but you wouldn't
even need like a tampon like you would
your body would tell you
when you're gonna get your period you
know what i'm saying like that's how in
tune
as humans we have the capability to be
with our bodies but we're told
um if you have a headache you know
taking ibuprofen
you might it's your body just telling
you you're dehydrated and you need a
glass of water
well you know we need to not be mad at
the signs and symptoms
you need to be grateful for the signs
and symptoms it's a calling because when
you feel a pit in your stomach
let that be a warning sign that you need
to pay attention to something
emotionally right
when something is failing health-wise
let that be a realization that
i need to figure out what the root cause
of this is
otherwise you'll just slowly die maybe a
little slower because you'll find a
medicine or have a treatment but
the root causes are really sourced from
the emotional i think i've heard like
the issues are in the tissues and you
know emotional body and
the manifestation of dis-ease in the
body
creates the disease is the disease so
there's so much
wrapped up in all that it's like i'm
grateful for the science now
yeah sometimes you just want to take the
ibuprofen
but sometimes i still do sometimes i
sometimes do
and i think medicine has a as a
wonderful place for trauma
yes like for like if something happens
an accident
uh something with you you break your leg
or if you
number one in the world when it comes to
trauma like we resolve like a quick
illness
yeah yeah there's there's the medicines
have their purpose for sure or
you know what you have a headache and
you have a meeting to go to and you're
like i just need to be clear
and you just so there's there's a place
for it for sure there's a place for
um for all of them i'm not even
excluding any of them there's a place
for all of them
thank god for modern medicine but you
know the the consistent
um treatment with them is the is kind of
i think more what we're talking about
yeah i think i when i when my mom died
and i was looking for
um spiritual guidance pretty much
anywhere i could get it because when my
mom passed um
i came to the conclusion that the
religion that i grew up with wasn't
giving me any comfort
so i was like i need i need comfort
right now i need grace i need
love i need i need something and the
religion that i grew up with as it was
structured for me
wasn't giving me anything it felt like a
cold cement like
floor you know and i needed like a warm
blanket in front of like a fireplace
sort of thing so i went so i went out
and looked and i
one of the conversations that i had and
this is eventually going to tie back to
the medicine i promised but i sat down
with a with a llama rinpoche
an um a hindu priest i guess
and he told me this little story that
the biggest
like the the biggest shock that he had
when he came to this side of the world
was the amount of pills that were
offering that were offered to him
upon any symptom of anything like he was
like a 40 year old man that
had never even probably taken ibuprofen
he would take like his teeth or whatever
and he was like
i have just been so surprised at how
people pull pills out of the person
offer them to me for every symptom that
i have
um so i think we're just kind of
conditioned
to to believe that
it resolves they resolve they resolve
that's the micro level but the macro
level is like we
want to everything fixed quickly yeah
and guess what you've been talking about
how long you've been on this journey
i've been on this journey for
years and years and it is it is a
journey but like you said
that's the point if the point of life is
ascension then
the point of life is the journey and
like don't be so mad at it and don't be
so don't be scared of it like it
is the point totally i got a message the
other day from a young lady
that was like aren't you so angry that
you have to do all this work that you
can't eat tortillas
and i thought about it for a second i
was like and my response was i was
angry for a while but
i've been able to turn it around to work
for me even professionally like
and that's where you have to turn those
um
incredibly uncomfortable or difficult
situations you have to try your best to
turn them around and make them work for
you like that's the process oh look that
is life now you have something unique to
offer which is
you know um a healthier version of these
foods like now you have a niche right
like just be yourself you'll
find a spot yes yes and that's and
that's the
and that's and that's i think the secret
to being truly inspiring it's it's not
really
doing it's being it's just in being if
i just have the balls to be marcella
that's gonna inspire somebody because
i'm living in authenticity i'm just
being me i'm just inhabiting my body i'm
just
being and that's that's enough to
inspire
you know and i've learned that the hard
way that when i try
so hard and to do what this other person
is doing and
i'm really just be man
if you just have the courage to be
that's enough
to like make people want to like
gravitate towards you like i've seen it
happen in real time in my life
it's helpful that's beautiful
and i can't think of a better way to end
it that's so great handstands you're so
awesome
thank you marcel i love you my friends
thank you for having me
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button